[Musique]
notre parti c'est le parti de la liberté
c'est le parti de la responsabilité le
de l'autorité de la solidarité
eh bien il faut qu'on l'exprimé pire en
même temps permettre des mesures en face
c'est bon on doit être l'endroit on
invente un projet de réconciliation
française la réconciliation française
qu'est ce que c'est c'est à la fois le
relèvement de la nation et la libération
des français
acceptons que y ait des gens qui soient
pas tout à fait d'accord sur tout mais
qui ont un idéal commun
si on se retrouve avec un centre mou
d'emmanuel macron pardon mais c'est
comme ça que je le définis et c'est mon
opinion et d extrême s'est jamais la
démocratie qui gagne ce canton veut
rassembler la gauche la droite et du
coup ce qui amène à faire des réformes à
moitié ça fait pas avancer le pays moi
quand j'entends emmanuel macron ans ou
40 oiseaux à fibre je suis souvent
d'accord avec eux quand je regarde ce
qu'ils font je trouve qu'au contraire
ils sont peut-être en dissociation entre
ce qu'ils disent et ce qu'ils font
donc si c'est pour faire semblant de
faire des réformes en chaque fois
faisant faire une loi et que cette loi
ne règle pas le problème
alors alors là oui il ya les électeurs
les attendent un projet pour leur ville
et ya pas d trottoir de droite et des
trottoirs de gauche et des trottoirs en
marche on décide de refaire des
trottoirs ou pas est un peu de
pragmatisme c'est ça s'est passé accor
de boutiques essayons de considérer que
les élections municipales c'est des
élections d'une personne en mer et qui a
un projet pour la ville pour la cité
certain nombre d'écoles coraniques sur
le territoire national n'est pas
suffisamment traité je pense qu'il ya
encore à l'heure où nous parlons des
lieux de culte qui sont tenus par des
extrémistes qui nourrit régulièrement
fermé que je pense que des mesures
d'éloignement hors du territoire
national d'individus qui sont des
prêcheurs de haine ne sont pas
suffisamment organisés je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts à
faire sur ce sujet qui doit d'ailleurs
rassemblé l'ensemble de la communauté
national du prg vous avez le djihadisme
qui opèrent de façon violente le
terrorisme mais il ya aussi une autre
réalité avec les frères aux salafistes
d'un islam politique conquérant qui
essaient de conquérir les esprits les
territoires qui est à l'oeuvre
aujourd'hui et fall nos félins grâce à
cet islamisme d'affirmations il faut
réaffirmer ce que nous sommes nous
sommes une république laïque
c'est inadmissible intolérable et
inacceptable
là dessus il ne doit pas tomber dans le
communautarisme isna
[Musique]